hello everybody a very good morning it
is seven o'clock here in the uk
welcome wherever you're watching us
around the world this morning i am live
here incentives in cornwall as the uk
prepares to host the g7 summit
which gets underway later on today it's
friday
the 11th of june a global shot in the
arm g7 leader is expected to commit to
provide
one billion coveted vaccine doses to the
rest of the world
with a hundred million coming from the
uk
we know that raging covert 19 in other
countries
holds back global growth raises
instability
and weakens governments
the stage is set the guests are arriving
the japanese prime minister
one of the first world leaders to touch
down in cornwall uh this morning
i'm going to be speaking to the foreign
secretary dominic raab and the shadow
foreign secretary lisa nandy
we'll also hear from local businesses
and politicians as the eyes of the world
focus
on cornwall plus rick stein's thumb jack
on hopes the summit will boost the
region's hospitality sector
the royal family will also play a key
role in today's events we'll see the
queen
the duke and duchess of cornwall and the
duke and duchess of cambridge
as well they're all meeting g7 leaders
later on today
also this morning 10 years on from the
winter-born view scandal how thousands
of adults with learning disabilities
are still being detained in mental
health hospitals
after a year on the touchline euro 2020
kicks off the summer of sport
in rome this evening and slightly
fresher conditions for today but still
mostly fine and dry then heating up
again through the weekend
i'll have more details later
good morning from cornwall we've got
missile this morning i'm being told by
my cameraman ed which is a cross between
mist and drizzle and it's not picked up
on the radars as far as rain is
concerned so
when many of those leaders are opening
their curtains this morning at the
beautiful
uh castle just on the hill there they'll
not be quite sure
when they look at that and think well i
said it wasn't going to rain hopefully
it will clear up for the next three days
the biggest issues
facing the world will discuss here in
centralized by political leaders at that
g7 summit
tackling the pandemic will feature
heavily with a pledge to give away
a billion doses of covered vaccines to
the world's poorest nations
a hundred million of those will come
from the uk
in the next year tomorrow the leaders
will toast
marshmallows in a barbecue on the beach
very nice
tonight it's a reception hosted by the
queen at the eden project
as our diplomatic editor dominic waghorn
reports
president biden and prime minister
johnson have renewed a partnership
forged in war
the atlantic charter to face the perils
of our time
in that spirit britain will now give 100
million vaccine doses to the world
over the next year to fight covid
america
500 million america
will be the arsenal of vaccines
in our fight against globe coven 19.
just as america was the arsenal
democracy during world war ii
together g7 leaders will bring with them
promises to give a billion vaccine doses
to the world
it needs two billion and as president
biden put it failure to vaccinate
everyone
endangers us all as long as the virus
rages elsewhere
there's a risk of new mutations that
could threaten our people
we know that raging covet 19 in other
countries
holds back global growth raises
instability
and weakens governments
when they meet here in a luxury hotel g7
leaders face an
awesome challenge seeing off grave
threats with they hope
renewed unity
but as they convene on cornwall's
historic coastline
differences are threatening to overcloud
their meeting
a summit that should be about allies
standing together united against common
looming threats
could instead be jeopardized by
divisions over northern ireland
that could leave its british hosts
beleaguered and isolated
the g7 must show that the rancor and
disunity of the trump years
are a thing of the past because while
this was going on the west's autocratic
rivals have been on the march
listen to the man who used to be in
charge of the western alliance
we are divided
they're too weak we
are characterized by self-doubt
and this must be changed we have to
change the moods we have to build up
more self-confidence
after the disharmony of recent years a
chance to put the band back together
joe biden wants america to lead the
world again
[Music]
will his allies take his cue and rise to
the challenge
dominic wagon sky news falmouth
[Music]
okay let's take a look at what will be
happening here in cornwall today should
we
this is day one of a three-day gathering
as i was saying while president biden is
already in town most world leaders
will be arriving in cornwall throughout
the course of the day
and this afternoon there'll be an
official welcome and a g7 family photo
we're very used to those aren't we
probably with a bit more social
distancing than that
then the duchess of cambridge and the
first lady
of the united states dr jill biden will
meet today for an engagement
and the queen will subsequently host a
reception for attending dignitaries at
the eden project this evening
joined by other members of the royal
family
meanwhile prince charles will host a
meeting of chief executives
and will be joined by u.s climate envoy
john kerry
and cop 26 president alok sharma
there are a range of big issues to be
discussed at this summit
climate change covid vaccines
and brexit amongst many many others
somebody knows an awful lot about this
sort of thing is the uk's former
ambassador to the u.s france
and turkey sir peter west mccoy hello to
peter it's great to talk to you thanks
for joining us
uh on the program this morning um what
do you think is going to be top of the
agenda
well i think president biden set out
what he thought was the main things on
his mind
uh when he was talking to prime minister
johnson yesterday
he wants international agreement and
real progress on
on global health on cyber security on
the strengthening of democracy after the
rather difficult period of the last few
years
he wants cyber security he wants
movement on trade and of course there's
a
an agreement which is almost complete on
global taxation levels which is quite
important but sometimes
gets forgotten so you know we're calling
it the vaccine summit to some extent
uh and it is very important i think that
the g7 leaders are agreeing
to send as many as a billion hopefully
more uh vaccines to pass the world which
have not been properly vaccinated but i
think all those issues are on the agenda
but what struck me yesterday
okay and also overnight is how useful it
has been to have president biden in the
united kingdom for if you like 24 hours
in advance of the summit which gives the
world a chance to see
the president of the united states you
know back uh
on the world stage reassuring smiling
and
a fully paid out member if you like of
the of the moral leadership
of the western community and i think
it's good it's good for
the united kingdom to have him here but
i think it's also a very good start for
president biden
uh now that he is finally able to leave
the shores of the united states and
start traveling
it's the first test certainly for joe
biden who's been the deputy
um on the world stage for many many
years before that but as you said
uh first real visit for him um how do
you think he'll get on
with the other leaders
president biden has always struck me as
a as a people person
okay he he loves relationships he's very
interested in what makes others tick
he's interested in what others need
from this or that negotiation he's
curious about
other cultures other parts of the world
he's immensely experienced
40 years or so in the united states
senate chair of the foreign relations
committee and so on
and he will know some of these leaders
quite well already he didn't
know boris johnson until they met
yesterday but i think that
those relationships will be good he's a
he's a very
warm and tactile person but he's uh
believes that his role
is indeed to forge really meaningful
partnerships with leaders of other
like-minded countries
and indeed to stand up to bad behavior
by leaders of
less likelihood countries but he will
want to find
um others ready to make common cause
with him on some of those really big
issues that i touched on just now
uh the pr machine would have us believe
that these two world leaders are getting
on like a house on fire
already but there is the specter
of brexit and we know that the uh the
president of the united states is not at
all happy
about any threat whatsoever to the
northern ireland agreement so
what impact do you think that's going to
have on talks behind the scenes
i think president biden was very clear
way back that he didn't think brexit was
a brilliant idea that it wasn't great
for britain wasn't great for
america that it wasn't great for the
european union either
and i think you know to take a phrase
from that wonderful musical hamilton
uh he would rather see britain in the
room where it happens
rather than outside uh as a spectator
but all that is if you like in the past
now
uh and so we are now um moving forward
yes
he knows that boris johnson was quite
cozy with his predecessor
uh yes he knows that he was an architect
of brexit but he is
a realistic politician he knows that the
prime minister of not only his host
but also the leader of one of america's
most important allies
so i think that you know those personal
things will be to some extent
uh put to one side and the focus will be
on what can we do what do we really need
to do
together to make the world a safer more
prosperous place so i think the
chemistry will be fine both are kind of
extrovert
people type people type presidents and
prime minister
and i think that uh the chemistry looks
to me though it's got off to a pretty
good start
you say put to one side and the
chemistry might be pretty good between
those two but then
enter stage left president macron who is
saying don't you even think about trying
to renegotiate any part of the brexit
deal because it is simply
not happening do you think there is a
possibility that brexit may
start to overshadow this g7 summit
i think there is that risk and it was um
it was very striking that just a few
days before the g7 summit before
president biden's visit
that his acting ambassador was asked to
go in and speak to the british
government in very firm terms
uh about the risk to the good friday
agreement and the risk to
stability if you like on the island of
ireland uh if we carried on
um refusing to implement if you like the
northern ireland protocol as part of the
withdrawal agreement
a protocol which the british government
freely negotiated itself and now has
some difficulty
about implementing for president biden
for many many years indeed going back
many generations
the whole issue of his uh irish ethnic
roots is very important
but more important that he cares deeply
about peace in the island of ireland
he was one of the architects of the
earlier president clinton initiatives
way back when i was first in washington
30 years ago in bringing an end to the
troubles and he cares deeply about
it so yes you're right that i think
anything which is going on
around the detailed implementation of
brexit
which turns out to be damaging to good
friday agreement and to stability and
peace on the island of valor this will
be a matter of grave concern
i'm sure it came up in the bilateral
yesterday and of course there are other
european
union heads of government and the
president of the commission who are
going to be in cornwall
who are all concerned about not
reopening the withdrawal agreement which
was so painfully negotiated
with the united kingdom so i think it is
an important part of the agenda
alongside those very big global issues
that everybody wants to make progress on
as well
and how much of these g7 events you'll
have seen
very many many of them over your uh
experience and
years are they just photo ops or does a
lot of work
actually get done behind the scenes
tons of work of course in the
preparation you know look at all the
things that you're seeing look at the
security look at the new roads the
strengthening of new key airport to take
air force one and all those things
um huge amount of effort goes into it
and i think it's wonderful for cornwall
i hope the mizzle
disappears and you get some nice
sunshine so we can see how marvelous it
is
but you know to be more serious for a
moment i do think that
for the leaders of these seven countries
to come together in person
especially when they've only been able
to talk through zoom and teams and so on
for the last
pretty much 18 months is important and i
think personal relationships do matter
there are some heads of government for
whom it doesn't make much difference
they go through the motions they read
the brief they
sign off what officials advise them to
do i would say that in the case of our
own prime minister
boris johnson and president biden who i
knew when he was vice president
that personal relationships and making
progress together
and understanding bottom line of the
other players these are really important
things
and especially after the four years of
president trump i think that president
biden
will really want to reassure his fellow
heads of government of like-minded
countries
that america is back and collegiate uh
and
this is not not so much the last four
years were a blip
but that it was very much not the end of
consensual internationalism
of america uh but that it was a four
years which is now
in the past and biden will be doing all
he possibly can
to show not only that america is back
for now but that america
is back for good quick thought before i
let you go it's a very big gathering
here certainly pulling out all the stops
barbecues on the beach with marshmallows
goodness knows
what else but to what extent is the uk
still a big player
uh in the g7 or are we just kidding
ourselves
playing host to a meeting like this is a
wonderful opportunity and it's
it is a challenge to any host government
to show what they can do
so it's nice if the sky shy if the sun
shines in the sky is blue but if you
haven't got that
nevertheless you can make everything
else work effectively i think this is
the sort of thing that the uk
is good at i'm thrilled to see that her
majesty is going down to the eden
project will be there this evening with
the prince of wales with the duke and
duchess of cambridge
i think our royal family uh uh
magnificent assets in terms of
britain's diplomacy in britain's place
in the world
and that will give a lot of pleasure i'm
sure to the visitors
i think we're good at this stuff we are
still on the top table of the united
nations security council at nato and so
on we're not any longer in the european
union
personally i regret that but that's
where we are now but i still
would say there's everything to play for
and if we are realistic about what we
mean by things like global written
and we work out where we can continue to
make a real difference for good
uh and for prosperity and engaging with
like-minded
countries then you know we can still
look forward to a meaningful
future where the other countries
continue to take the
uk seriously and don't begin to write us
off as some threatened to do
once they saw the direction that brexit
was going in
okay so peter westmore always great to
talk to you thanks for taking the time
this morning thank you
let's bring in our political
correspondent rob powell who's been
listening
uh to what the former ambassador had to
say and also to look ahead to the g7
summit later on today good morning rob
morning yeah i think what was
interesting in what zupita was saying
was that despite i think
maybe some passed on paper differences
between boris johnson and joe biden
he was sort of suggesting that the
combination of a lot of big issues that
need tackling
be it climate change be it the pandemic
be it cyber security
mixed up with the sort of affability
that these two men have the personal
relationship which seems to have got off
to a good start should hopefully get
them through
that's not to say though that there
aren't tensions bubbling
um under the water i think largely
issues around northern ireland were sort
of stomped down below the water line
yesterday whether that changes when
emanuel macron flies in this morning
when the eu council president and the
president of the european commission
come later today
um as well that remains um to be seen in
terms of what we'll see later today
i think very much the majority of the
pictures coming out of where urk
today will be the sort of fun friendly
side of the g7
in terms of as you say the big family
photos the royals visiting dinner at the
eden project
before really the tough talk and the
more thorny issues
start tomorrow in terms of today's big
topic that the government wants to talk
about anyway
vaccine sharing sharing the surplus
of our own jab stocks i think maybe the
uk government is hoping
that by pulling other countries in to
donate their jabs
this could be one of those issues that
allows these countries to coalesce
and to come together and to present a
united front on the world stage
okay for now rob thank you still to come
on the program for you
this morning live from center ice which
issues does
labor want prioritised at the g7 meeting
the shadow foreign secretary lisa nundy
will tell us
at 7 40. at 5
8 i'll be speaking exclusively to the
foreign secretary dominic raab
about that pledge to donate a hundred
million coveted vaccine doses
to poorer nations and his hopes for the
summit
and i'm going to be asking also the
former australian prime minister julia
gillard about her plea
to g7 leaders to give girls better
access
that is at 8 20.
so all of that to come as i said
throughout the course of the morning do
not go anywhere before
that though i want to tell you about the
family of a man with autism
and a learning disability he's trying to
get him released from a mental health
hospital
claiming the care that he has been
receiving has made his condition
even worse he's one of more than 2 000
people being held in such units in
england despite government promises to
reduce that number
here's gerard tubb with more this was a
couple of months before
he wasn't great but he was better
becky davis is convinced her 26 year old
brother
should not be in the mental hospital
where he's been held for three years
we're not identifying him to protect his
privacy
he has autism and a learning disability
and was confined when his mental health
deteriorated
we had a good period of where he was
settled for a good six to 12 months
um but obviously there was nowhere for
him to go
so he had to stay there so he kept
asking when he wanted to come home
and we couldn't give him an answer which
then made him deteriorate
ten years ago the government set a
target to reduce the number of people
held in mental health assessment and
treatment units
in the wake of the winter-born view
scandal when abuse at a private hospital
near bristol was exposed
the target has been missed twice and has
now been moved to 2024.
a specialist lawyer told us a shortage
of suitable community facilities
is partly to blame you don't see those
community services
necessarily as much as you you need to
because quite a lot of time they require
bespoke packages
um or particular parts of care which
perhaps aren't you know aren't
straightforward to organize
and it's about everyone working
collaboratively to try and actually
achieve that and unless that happens
um these individuals unfortunately end
up being stuck in hospital
ready to be discharged but for a
community package being in place which
is the worst scenario
becky's brother is being held in a
hospital run by the teas-esque and weir
valleys nhs trust
which told us its staff are dedicated to
providing the best possible care for
individuals
and that it makes every effort to
support adults with a learning
disability
to live in the community mps debated the
missed targets this week
to mark the 10th anniversary of the
winterbourne view scandal
it is a complete failure of government
to take the action
that they pledged to do when that
appalling abuse was revealed
why should autistic people and people
learning disabilities be treated this
way
i want to show that they're not
invisible that we do care and that we
are listening to their issues
the department for health and social
care told us it is determined to
continue to reduce the number of people
with learning disabilities
and autistic people in mental health
hospitals and is investing 62
million pounds in community services and
supporting discharges
becky has now found community
accommodation for her brother
and hopes he can be released from
hospital soon
gerard tubbs sky news first
more from the g7 summit live here
incentives in just a moment but also
making the news for you this morning
uh figures released in the last few
moments show a big
rise in gdp the office of national
statistics says it grew 2.3
in april but that's still still nearly
four percent below
pre-pandemic levels one of the biggest
video games companies in the world has
become the victim of a cyber attack
electronic arts has revealed the coding
to build some of its
best-selling games has been stolen but
claims the theft will not
impact on its business
it's claimed nearly half of the clothes
sold by leading fast fashion brands are
made
entirely from non-recycled plastics the
royal society for the arts
analyzed more than 10 000 items of
women's clothing
advertised by major online retailers
mps say young people are at risk of
retiring with inadequate
income later in life because they can't
afford to make pension contributions
the commons public accounts committee
says the treasury hasn't done enough
to ensure that people understand the
real value of their pension
almost a hundred recipients of honours
are backing a campaign for the
government to replace
the title empire with excellence they
say it would recognize britain's
colonial
imperialist past and the harm and trauma
it had caused the cabinet office says
there are no plans
to change the wording
now the adventures of a herd of
elephants have become one of the biggest
news stories
in china we showed you the pictures
didn't we earlier on in the week the
asian elephants started trekking across
the country in march of last year
they headed north from a nature reserve
on the border with myanmar
by the end of the year they traveled
more than 200 miles reaching
moyjan county most of them have reached
kunming city that's a journey of more
than
300 miles the equivalent of walking from
yorkshire
to here in cornwall our asia
correspondent tom cheshire reports
the elephants have packed their trunks
said goodbye to the jungle
and gone off with a trumpety trump on a
mysterious tour around southern china
this herd has been on the move for more
than a year going all the way from their
home on a wildlife reserve
to the big city lights of kunming the
provincial capital
they've been wreaking havoc raiding
farms for food and water
and show no signs of stopping and no one
really
knows why in the past years the number
of the elephants has increased
because protein has gained but meanwhile
the num
uh the population in the area
has also increased uh and more lands
that can be the potential hepatitis for
elephants has been occupied
by by human activities
authorities have been trying to keep
people out of their path constantly
filming them with drones to keep track
and as a result they've become social
media stars
people all around china have been
following every development
like when these calves found themselves
in a spot of bother
and hundreds of millions of people
watched this video actually quite a rare
sight in the natural world
of the elephants taking a well-deserved
nap on the ground
even far away in the capital beijing
most people have an opinion
[Music]
on
foreign
and so off they continue to trot we can
never
truly know the mind of an elephant and
perhaps they do not know their own
we can only wish them well on their
odyssey and hope they find what they're
looking for
tom cheshire sky news beijing
absolutely love elephants i was saying
earlier on in the week that they can
actually communicate with each other two
miles apart and because of the level of
the pitch
we can't hear with the human ear so
that's probably how they're
managing to all stay together because
you're with me so early i'm going to
treat you to a little look
at centaurus i'm going to move out of
the way and ed will show you this is the
harbour here at
sentais very beautiful even though we've
got a bit of missile this morning that's
going to burn off i believe a bit later
on for these g7
world leaders but you can imagine the
sort of security that is here as a
result
of that officers on jet skis just
keeping an eye not only here but
around the bay as well where the world
leaders will be waking up for their
breakfast this morning
eleven thousand police officers are here
in um sendai's bay from all around
the country they're actually being
housed out on a cruise ship at sea
because there literally wasn't enough
room for them all on land 150
sniffer dogs as well bomb disposal teams
we've seen
plenty of those and i'm not sure ed if
you can show me the
warship uh the just behind there but
that i think is the tamar and the tamar
was the one you may remember
that actually went to jersey quite
recently during that fishing wars
with some of the fishing vessels from um
the french fishermen who were very
unhappy about what was happening as far
as brexit was concerned i believe that
is tamar
alongside that her sister ships tyne
ranger
frigate um blazer northumberland
and jersey are all here as well
so that gives you a little bit of an
idea of what's going on here in the
harbour
this morning it's going to be an
absolutely packed day
for the politicians as more and more of
them arrive the big question is i
suppose is is it going to be sunny
for their barbecue later on
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it's actually going to be
quite a cloudy day
across parts of cornwall the south west
generally and across
parts of wales although it's murky this
morning yes the murky conditions will
generally clear from southern coastal
areas but
across the southwest it's likely to stay
murky for much of the day cloudy
with some patchy light rain and drizzle
elsewhere we're seeing some bright or
sunny spells developing and across
northern and western parts of england
and wales this morning there's patchy
light rain and drizzle it's that front
with the cloud that's working its way
southwards this afternoon to southern
parts of wales parts of the midlands
down towards the southwest so
a dull day there central southern and
eastern areas of england
lots of sunshine still very warm but
behind that front slightly cooler but
still warm enough with sunny spells but
blustery showers over northern scotland
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
[Music]
coming up as the g7 summit begins
here in cornwall this morning we'll
speak with the shadow foreign secretary
lisa nandy in just a moment stay tuned
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello again a very good morning to you
we are live incentives
for you this morning ahead of the g7
summit those noises off um the
deliveries for obviously you can imagine
just how busy it is here on the seafront
not least because it's the middle of the
summer but also
because of the extra people that are
here as a result of the g7 summit
and they're delivering all the beers and
things for the pubs on the sea front
we'll show you a bit later on
those leaders have made a big promise to
tackle the global pandemic while they're
here
at the start of the summit they're
expecting to give a billion doses of
coronavirus vaccines to help countries
trying to stop the spread of covid
19. amongst them of course africa
and our africa correspondent john sparks
has been tracking the spread of the
virus there
and joins us from johannesburg this
morning hello to
john so one of the theories was that
every time somebody in the western world
developed world got a jab in the arm
that should happen in places like africa
as well where are we with that good
morning
good morning kay well it's really been
very much a two-track vaccination
process
people in the wealthier countries in the
the so-called west have been getting
vaccines have access to vaccines
people in places like africa simply have
not been and pressure has been building
on the u.s countries like the u.s the uk
where the majority of people have had
access to a vaccine to spell out how
they are going to help developing world
countries
get access to to sufficient supplies and
this is a particularly pressing issue
here in africa where
a third wave of infection is now taking
root
while vaccination rates remain pitifully
low we're talking about
less than one percent of the population
in africa have
received or have been fully vaccinated
even in south africa with a relatively
advanced economy and health care system
point eight percent of the population
here has been
fully vaccinated in response to the uk
say it
says it's going to donate 100 million
doses that are surplus to its
requirements
to kovacs 80 of those going to kovacs
the un led
vaccine sharing facility the americans
say they're going to buy
500 million pfizer vaccines 200 million
they say by the end of the year
boris johnson calling this a massive
step to beat the pandemic for good
but i think a lot of people in the
public health world we'll call that
an overstatement we've just come back
from lesotho i can tell you that in
lesotho
key health workers are still trying to
get their first of a two dose
vaccine they are so far behind there the
general public have
no possibility of getting a vaccine and
the experience in lesotho is also the
experience of africa
as a whole where they have received 50
million jabs but they're going to need
billions they're going to need billions
of vaccines the population of the
continent is 1.3
billion and we just don't have the
infrastructure the financial support to
provide those vaccines
the uk says it will supply 5 million by
the end of september the who is looking
for 225 million by at the end of
september to try and vaccinate 10
percent of the population
on the continent so there is such a long
way
to go with this it's a start i think
that's all we can say
okay for now thanks so much indeed john
and we'll certainly be putting that
to the foreign secretary when he joins
us exclusively just after eight o'clock
this morning 100 million doses pledged
by the uk will that be
enough let's ask should we the shadow
foreign secretary who's joining us now
lisa nandi
um hello to you lisa nandy lots to talk
about let's let's start where we
finished off there with a hundred
million doses
from the uk um is that going to be
enough
it's just a start where should we go
from here
well it it is just a start but it's a
welcome start because
there's a very very strong case for
getting the vaccine out to frontline
healthcare workers
around the world in countries where
they're simply being overwhelmed and
doing that relatively quickly but what
we need to get from
this summit is an agreement about a plan
to actually ramp up capacity around the
world and get the vaccine out
to every corner of the globe we've been
locked in a debate about should we send
more
from britain or should we administer
those vaccines here in britain the truth
is that we have to do both and that
means that we need to invest
in factories in capacity in countries
where they have none at the moment it
means we need to
invest in health care systems in other
countries
in order to make sure they can actually
administer the vaccine because in many
places that's a real problem
as well and if if g7 leaders can reach
an agreement on that it won't just be
good for the world us fulfilling our
moral duty it will also
as the imf said recently represent the
biggest return on investment in modern
history
because the economic fallout of the
failure to tackle
kovid 19 is going to come back to visit
us here in britain very very quickly
just one of the issues that the g7
leaders are going to be discussing here
in cornwall brexit is going to be
another
problem potentially it would appear for
the government we know
already that uh president biden not at
all happy about anything that might
derail the uh good friday agreement and
then uh president macron
uh flying in today giving another
headache for
uh the prime minister it would seem how
important do you think it is that
brexit's on the agenda here
well i think brexit needs to just be
resolved in order that we can move on
and deal with the really pressing issues
covid19
climate change global tax reform which
would bring billions to britain
but which the uk is holding out against
and it's hard to think of the prime
minister who's going into a g7 summit as
the host in a worst
state he's not only at loggerheads with
the eu five years after we voted to
leave
he's also been rebuked by the president
of the united states
and he's locked in a battle with his own
back ventures in the tory party
over international aid which is a key
plank of his global britain policy
i think the prime minister just needs to
resolve these things it shouldn't take
the president of the united states
to tell the uk prime minister that he
ought to uphold
the peace agreement in northern ireland
that ought to be an article of faith
for any uk prime minister and what we
need to see from boris johnson is not
just
the warm words which he he had yesterday
it was welcome to hear him and president
biden
affirm their commitment to upholding the
good friday agreement
we now need to see him just use some
creativity and good will
to reduce the friction in the irish sea
and then just get on with delivering for
priorities that are actually going to be
of enormous benefit to britain
this is supposed to be a green summit we
know that the um
prime minister's already been criticized
for flying in on
a private jet i mean your own leader not
without guilt on things like that he i
believe he flew up to newcastle recently
um in order edinburgh forgive me in
order to uh put a
an ad together for being green um
we all need to do more in order to try
to save the planet there are
demonstrators i don't know if we can see
them ed just behind me saying
if the sea dies then we die
what more do we need to start to do what
more do we need our leaders need to do
to try to save the planet
i think it's right to say that we all
need to take some personal
responsibility for this and i think my
sense is that most people do
try to cut down on their carbon
footprint
but individual action alone is not going
to be enough we need a global agreement
and it's six months to go until the uk
co-hosts
one of the most important summits
imaginable
the cop 26 in glasgow where we're going
to have to reach an agreement on the
action
that is going to be taken to get us to
climate safety
this is a huge environmental catastrophe
waiting to happen but it's also an
economic catastrophe as well
with so much of the world's pensions
savings
invested in fossil fuels that there's a
huge economic fallout if we don't get
this right for ordinary people across
this country
so this is the summit where we need an
agreement about that the prime minister
ought to be urging other world leaders
to sign up to binding
targets not in decades to come but in
this coming
decade the trouble is he goes into it
having
you know as you alluded to with the
issue about the plane
having not taken the action necessary at
home in order to get us to climate
safety so while germany and france are
turning up at this summit
with a huge green stimulus on the table
the united states as well
the uk's plan to get us to climate
safety had just four billion of new
money that pales into insignificance
compared to the two trillion
in green stimulus that president biden
is offering and it means that britain
will be
behind the curve in terms of creating
the green clean
energy jobs of the future that could
help to level up the country so that
there are two things at stake here for
the prime minister
as well as the very pressing issue of
climate safety his global britain agenda
which has to deliver andy's leveling up
agenda as well
which should be delivering those clean
energy jobs here at home
okay i mean twice in a week you've
indulged me on the program miss monday i
better let you go
and not override my luck thank you very
much
thank you thanks a lot
now better late than never the european
football championships finally
kicks off this evening many matches have
been moved to wembley
with fun numbers drastically cut due to
the pandemic
shingee maraki reports
the build-up is nearly over a year later
than planned
the biggest sporting event since the
pandemic brought life to a standstill is
set to begin
with england scotland and wales in
contention
the hope is that the european football
championships will help lift the spirits
of the nations
i'm getting a bit of that 1996 vibe
starting to go on now you know that
that real sense of excitement and and
involvement
and national interest and of course the
pandemic is
is adding to that
in many ways that feel good factor will
look and sound very different
before the passion agony and ecstasy
that come with watching the beautiful
game
will come precautions social distancing
measures are in place at the 11 stadiums
hosting the tournament
while capacity at many of the grounds
including in london
and glasgow is limited a ticket
will no longer be enough for fans coming
to watch the games here at wembley
in a sign of the times they will need to
show proof of full vaccination
or a negative cov test to enter the
stadium
for people watching the game away from
stands in pubs bars and restaurants
the fun will also be more organized than
usual
this pub in surrey is expecting the
euros to boost profits
but they face a balancing act between
serving pints and enforcing restrictions
we are certainly expecting a bit of a
bump uh especially on the england games
where most of our pubs
are sold out already fully booked um
so which is great as far as i'm
concerned because it means
we can monitor the numbers and all that
and and
not have hundreds of people turn up or
just expecting a table
covet isn't the only concern ahead of
the event the controversy
around fans brewing england players
decision to take the knee will continue
to be a talking point
i cannot understand the mentality of any
fan who pays for a ticket
travels to a stadium to support the team
and then the first thing they do is the
referee bros the whistle is to boo their
own players it's beyond comprehension
the tournament kicks off tonight in rome
before wales led by gareth bale become
the first of the british sides to play
tomorrow
taking on switzerland in baku
england preparing as usual at st
george's park hosts croatia at wembley
on sunday
and scotland will hope to make the most
of their home advantage
and they face the czech republic at
hamden park on monday
for fans who have had to wait an extra
12 months for this feast of european
football
the hope is that 2021 will be the odd
year the trophy comes home
shinki mararike sky news
i'm sure those games will be on here in
many of the pubs and restaurants
at sendtimes the first day of the g7
summit here in cornwall beautiful
beautiful start to your morning
hopefully you uh
appreciate the view just as much as we
do we're speaking to the
police and crimes commissioner for the
region in just a moment
[Music]
well essentially it's uh instead of
going to a campsite you carry your tent
on your back
and you take it up about wherever you
want to go where is the freedom of being
able to go
wherever you like isn't it i mean we
climb mountains
we go by toms and spend the night there
get the drone out and we do youtube
channels as well and
we love it don't we yeah keeps him off
his pc as well which is the main thing
he enjoys it don't ya he doesn't like
the climb you usually have to climb 500
600 meters high with the bag on the back
so it's
it could be quite hard but once you gets
up there you love it don't you early
well where have we gone we've been to
red squeeze it's all also around the
lakes
last week were to be going through last
week and c3 fell
seathwaite fell we went about sprinkling
tom place fell
um which is the best one would you say
he likes angle tar he likes all the ones
by the water because
he tends to be easier to get to for the
it's so good i mean it gets me and him
out together and
that's what we like really but if
father's son bonding isn't it josh's
father and some bandit
[Applause]
[Music]
this monastery is under the protection
for now of russian peacekeepers
i'm diana magnay and i'm sky's russia
correspondent based here in moscow
i witnessed the despair of the armenians
in nagorno-karabakh
it's armenians who've abandoned these
villages now
[Music]
despite what their strategy is i'm not
sure but they have made
some arrests already today
they can't arrest everybody we take you
to the heart of the stories that shape
our world
this clearly says i love hitler
[Music]
russia insists that its military buildup
in the arctic is purely defensive
[Music]
my name is fatima zanzilla the founder
of ikista from kuwait where we face many
environmental
problems related to waste pollution the
frustration
and lack of information we are
collecting recyclables
from houses schools and businesses in
order to recycle them
exchange if you recycle to get a treat
[Music]
did you know symptoms of hay fever can
develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
it's cloudy for many places to start
with particularly across parts of the
west with some rain
mainly over the hills but there will be
sunny spells developing into the
afternoon
however parts of central and
southwestern areas will be rather cloudy
with patchy light rain and drizzle and
showers over northern parts of scotland
and slightly fresher compared to
recently
pollen levels are now very high in some
spots mainly across the midlands central
southern and eastern england today
whereas wales and the north of england
will experience moderate levels and
scotland and northern ireland
will be low grass pollen is now in peak
season fungal spores are at medium risk
and there's lots of weed pollen too
the pollen reports sponsored by philips
connected air purifiers
hello again everybody have a very warm
welcome from scent ives this morning as
the leaders of the world's richest
nations along with diplomats the media
and protesters descend on cornwall what
are the
security concerns here someone who knows
all about it
is the devon and cornwall police and
crime commissioner and that's alison
hernandez hello to you hello
lovely to see you this morning good
morning and we've seen some of your guys
already this morning on a jet ski just
uh patrolling making sure everything's
as it should be what sort of
planning has gone into making the events
of the next few days as successful as
possible
an absolutely huge amount of planning in
fact in some of the early stages there
were about 50 officers
in preparing for this that started to
expand about 200
just to get the logistics right we're
working in partnership with a lot of
agencies as well and particularly the
armed forces so
this isn't just a policing and security
of the event it's actually a huge
partnership
with everybody down here to keep us safe
and that's how we work down here we're
surrounded by sea on three sides so it's
the only way to do it yeah
very tricky though some of the roads are
very narrow as i was driving down here
yesterday
you know i've got one of those suvs and
it was quite tight for me apparently the
beast which is the presidential card
can't fit down these roads
so that's causing you all sorts of
problems as well well we have a largely
rural road network down here in fact one
of the things we're really concerned
about is some of the people who get
killed on our roads so
we're very take it very seriously um i
think the challenges for us is that the
locals are familiar with all of these
roads and uh
i think when you've got vehicles that
are not used to it um it is a surprise
and i think but it's part of our
quaintness
it's part of why we like it down here
and it does sort of keep those types out
normally so
there's something about they're very
special to be able to come down here and
be able to experience it
okay six and a half thousand police
officers from all around the country i
think you're hosting some of them out on
cruise ships because there isn't enough
bed space uh on the mainland um how
difficult is it how much of a challenge
to get all of those uh police services
to work together well firstly this is an
opportunity to showcase uk policing
really you know we are largely an
unarmed police
experience in the uk so we're really
proud to be able to do it
we've got every force represented in
cornwall at the moment that's
unusual that's never happened in the
country before
and actually one of the things that
we've been doing is we want to make sure
that they're doing it the devon and
cornwall way
so they're all arriving at hq in exeter
i call it they're getting a bit sheep
dipped into the way that we do things
around here
and then they're coming down to cornwall
so yeah it's been a bit of a logistical
challenge just for the accommodation
to you know supply that for all those
officers but we've done it
we've made it now we're moving into the
policing element of it obviously and we
will see what happens now as we move
into that operational aspect
and what are the biggest threats to the
public for us at the moment
i would say usual crime is still
happening let's not forget that we might
have a g7 summit
we are one of the lowest crime areas in
the country so
that's why we have so many visitors
number one domestic tourist destination
but it's just the usual stuff that they
need to be thinking about
i want to make sure that people actually
reach out to policing if they need them
in this
time particularly those who are
experiencing all sorts of crimes like
domestic
abuse or if you're having anything
that's happening to you in your home do
feel free to reach out to the police i
don't want them to think
they're not available for local people
at the moment and covid is a big
issue for you i know there's a
restaurant on a hotel literally just up
the coast from where we are
now they've had to close because i think
about 13 of their staff contracted
uh covert out of 18 of them kovit is a
big problem with so many people in such
a small space
well we had the summer last year here
and i have to reassure people you know
when we opened up after some of the uh
lockdowns we had loads of tourists come
and visit and we didn't have a spike in
terms of the covid so i think people are
generally keeping themselves safe
i think the fact that they're doing
their regular testing is good that
they're identifying it early
and that's the way that we can keep most
people then assured that it's safe to
come down here and enjoy themselves
uh you're pleased that they're all here
all the g7 will leaders you'll be
pleased when they've gone
oh the funny thing is i made a joke this
morning because obviously devon and
cornwell in the aisles of silly you know
some of them are not going to feel
what's happening in cornwall at the
moment
it will pass many people by um so it
really it's a bit about
the media explaining what g7 is doing
some of the important talks that they're
having
um but i think when they're gone
everyone's going to be a bit of a sigh
of a relief
uh a bit of an opportunity to take a
breath uh especially the policing team
we've worked tirelessly
to actually get this preparation in
order okay i know you're very busy so
i'll let you go it's good to talk to you
allison
thank you very much indeed the uh crime
commissioner here
in devon and cornwall uh it's we've got
some missiles there's apparently
missiles a word is that right alice
yeah a missile which is like mist and
drizzle together
but it's going to burn off later on i
hope let's find out with nas
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it is going to be feeling
slightly cooler or slightly less warm
across many areas for today but then as
we head into the weekend it heats up
once again and for some spots there will
be
a heatwave developing this morning it's
mild it's muggy fairly cloudy as well
there's
coastal fog around southern and western
areas also patchy light rain and drizzle
across the north and west of england and
wales
showers over northern scotland and they
will continue across the north and west
of scotland perhaps to the northwest of
island later where the winds are going
to remain strong the patchy light rain
and drizzle will sink southwards to the
midlands
southern wales and the southwest of
england so a cloudy
murky day down towards cornwall today
but central southern and eastern england
very warm and sunny less warm but bright
elsewhere
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
that's our first hour already done here
incentives ahead of the g7
summit opening later on today let me
show you around even though there is a
bit of missile
as i was saying and you heard there from
naz people still out
on the beach uh exercising their dogs
this morning we've seen
an awful lot of police officers around
as well many of them on jet skis
making sure not only the g7 leaders but
also the people here
in devon and cornwall either locals or
people that are here
on holiday at this time of year are all
being kept safe there are one or two
demonstrators
as though well they were pretty noisy
with their fog horns earlier this
morning
but that has quietened down a little bit
for now i'm just going to move out of
the way and then we can
give you a lovely nice pan around and
look at scent ives
harbour i can tell you coming up in just
a few moments time
we will be hearing from the foreign
secretary dominic ram speaking to us
exclusively
here on sky news stay tuned
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
done
you